hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar DNA and RNA sequencing
sample prep automating simple to complex
methods I'm Judy O'Rourke of lab roots
and I'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminars
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences this webinar is
actually the second presentation in a
three-part series on laboratory
automation solutions for smaller NGS
labs those that are less familiar with
automation who are interested in
standardizing wore clothes and saving
costs through improved efficiency and
results this year Beckman Coulter life
science is celebrating 30 years in
automation as they continue to provide
liquid handling solutions to help
accelerate reliable results the dr
scientific discovery Beckman offers a
full range of flexible and scalable
biomech automated workstations and
integrated systems automate genomic
cellular protein and other work were
closed and a wide variety of research
areas including agriculture cancer and
infectious diseases cardiovascular
forensics and neurodegenerative
disorders for genomic applications
biomech automated workstations are
complemented by a growing portfolio of
nucleic acid extraction and purification
kits built on the company's patented
solid-phase reversible immobilization
SPR I magnetic bead technology let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the sheet button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the
slide window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green two and
a button at lower left before you meet
the speakers I want to rely is that a
serious poll questions will appear on
your screen during today's presentation
you may select your answers then close
the poll questions by clicking on the X
in the right corner I now present
today's speakers David Horvath MS and
Zacks missed ms who are both senior
application scientists for beckman
coulter life sciences david automates
propriety and third party next
generation sequencing chemistry he has a
master's of science and medical and
molecular genetics from the Indiana
University School of Medicine David's
career experiences span a broad range of
life science fields including forensic
DNA analysis medical diagnostics and
agricultural biotech Zac automates
propriety and third-party
next-generation sequencing kits he has
master's in environmental science from
Indiana University previously exact
worked at the university center for
genomics and bioinformatics as a project
scientist David will now begin his
presentation hi welcome everybody just
to recap from the first series we
started off talking about the
introduction to automating NGS workflows
today's topic will expand on specific
DNA and RNA sequencing applications and
then the carriage join us for the third
segment we'll be talking about on
meeting NGS sample prep for these
applications so a brief overview of the
first webinar series reviewed the
typical NGS workflow and while all
sequencing chemistry's are different the
typical NGS workflow involves general
processes such as we age
addition for various enzymatic reactions
temperature-controlled incubations
thermos cycling region storage debased
cleanups with am pure XP or spry be
technology and beef a cat target capture
so what we do is we we string those
different modules together to create
various sequencing workflows include
workflow is vary in length and
complexity but in general they comprised
those general processes the next part of
part 1 webinar was to describe our
application development process for
market research to building
collaborative partnerships scoping
requirements and features of
applications and then bridging that into
method development and optimization
followed by data generation and
generation of application though it's
posters etc followed by an internal
quality review process and then finally
actually doing the application
installations at the customer site with
post installation support and we also
have some software features and
highlights specifically related to our
new addition by momentum launcher and
kind of network setup as well as some
data reporting function at functionality
with our dart data acquisition and
reporting tool so I encourage you to
check the webinar online with you missed
part one so today's taka will feature
several DNA seek and RNA seek workflows
that we have automated and DNA
sequencing primarily is but it's a whole
genome sequencing or target capture so
whole genome sequencing essentially the
characterization of genetic variation of
mutations across in organisms entire
genome it can include de novo sequencing
or generating the initial reference
genomes of new species more typically
people will be using whole genome
sequencing to do ricci qin Singh which
is mapping sequencing results against
the reference genome in order to
identify Smith variants copy number
insertions deletions or large structural
variants various applications for whole
genome sequencing would include
personalized medicine predictive
medicine infectious disease strand
identification metagenomics as well as
others so this is a typical whole genome
sequencing workflow is you start off
with fragmentation of your sample
followed by and repair and then a
tailing adding the adapter by getting
the adapter which would include the
sequence-specific adapter as well as a
sample specific barcode index for
multiplexing sequencing reactions and
then typically followed by a pcr
enrichment stuff alternatively there is
a tagging tation protocol in which the
fragmentation the ligation are all
wrapped up into one step followed by pcr
enrichment that's transposon mediated
and the nicking of the genome happens
along with the ligation in one reaction
so various challenge points associated
with whole genome sequencing our ability
to accommodate a wide range of sample
inputs so we have various automation
solutions that provide use the user
interface provides flexibility of sample
input and adjust the protocol steps
automatically we also have a challenge
with accurately sized selecting
fragments across a wide range of
fragment sizes so our protocol
parameters will again automatically
adjust and match appropriately to the
sample input and Fryman size selection
using our proven sprite magnetic be
technology facilitates high-throughput
processing in microtiter plates
providing consistent results from sample
to sample
and run to run in addition complex
lengthy protocols require extensive
hands-on time and sample manipulation
Beckham culture automated sequencing
applications require minimal upfront set
up with modular workflows that provide a
balance of scheduling flexibility and
significant walk away time in next I'll
describe two different sequencing
applications to demonstrate how we've
automated a whole genome sequencing
process since this is a small last
campaign we want to focus on the ability
to maximize efficiency on our small
platform the bottleneck 4000 and here we
have an example of a bottleneck 4000
application for the alumina to see DNA
attr for you as well the nano DNA
methods what we've done is combine both
sequencing chemistry's into one
streamlined workflow if you're familiar
with both these chemistry protocols pcr
free and nano are essentially the same
protocol with the exception of the pcr
enrichment step at the end which is
included in the nano DNA protocol so we
we've made combine both those
applications so that either workflow is
available what that does is allow the
method to accommodate a wide range of
input DNA so 100 nanograms input for the
nano protocol up to my grams of input
for pcr free protocol so on the graphic
to the right it's our workflow so the
first column would be the fragmentation
clean up through size selection steps
with a break point corresponding to
Illumina's recommended stage stop point
followed by methods section to a
tailoring ligations ligation cleanups
for the pcr free method the process
would stop there and that you were
running the nano method you would have
the option to continue
on to the third section which is the DNA
regiment followed by the final PCR clean
up so all of our methods include a
user-friendly user interface that
provides all of the modular options that
are available with the for the manual
protocol as well as extra features that
are associated with our automation
protocol the bomb 94,000 provides
similar message options flexibility as
you'd expect from a larger NX and FX
platforms it's the optimal instruments
platform for low to medium throughput
laboratories canoe but it's also
scalable 296 sample or close as labs
makes the transition to the larger and X
or FX platform it can accommodate up to
24 samples per run anywhere from 1 to 24
and includes modular processing of
protocol sections so as a met as I
mentioned before fragmentation to site
selection can be performed an
independent run from the a tailing of
migration reactions or subsequent pcr
cleanups there is flexible adaptable a
blur and transfer options there's
optional integrated thermal cycling
which provides true operating capability
and also called the fixes cost-effective
disposal disposable fifth allocation
method timings are consistent with or
faster than manual processing is to
scale up the sample number DNA ggf free
workflow can be accomplished in
approximately five and a half hours
including 15 minutes of manual setup
time the Nano portion of the protocol
can be created completed in
approximately seven hours including
manual setup of approximately 15 minutes
this is an example of the biomech 4000
deck highly flexible for this particular
method we only use three tip boxes for
the entire PDF free or nano method for
up to 24 samples we have a mixture of
single and a channel pipetting tools
which provide balance of precious
reagent
degree and efficient cleanups we have
temperature controlled reagent storage
ensuring robust reaction chemistry and
then the duck is flexible allowing for
optional integration of the thermocycler
we use stack labware to maximize x space
when possible and that allows the the
greatest number of samples to be
processed with the smaller deck
footprint so here is final data from our
automated of electricity in a PDF free
and nana workflows so you can see
consistency on bioanalyzer data between
replicas and sufficient library yield
for pcr free libraries approximately six
to seven animal the same consistency for
our nano DNA libraries and very high
yields for for those about the kids
approximately 80 nanomolar so highly
sufficient yields or sequencing results
now the thumb of this presentation we do
not have biomech 4000 specific sequence
can get available but feel free to reach
out to an application scientist exactly
myself or any of our field application
scientists in the near future and will
be able to share that data with you the
second example is the Swift Biosciences
excel ng s 2 s plus method similar to
the alumina method this is a TCR free or
PCR enrichment workflow mm-hmm it
provides either option it has on dexter
recycling and 96 pcr free libraries can
be completed in approximately four and a
half hours so this method is developed
on the biomech FX and the associated
data was generated using that platform
although the method is scalable to a
violent 4000 platform just as the PCR
free nano pcr free and nano methods work
the workflow years broken into two
different parts methods section 1
includes the fragmentation
repair reactions ligation reaction
reactions and clean up following those
reactions there's a safe stop point and
the second part of the method includes
the PCR in Richmond and clean up steps
who they have the options are running
the full protocol or just one or just
the other again this method includes a
very customizable user interface if
you're familiar with the Swift protocol
there's multiple options for sample
input range and fragment size the
combination of those two options drives
different sprite cleanup conditions so
the the benefit of running through our
user interface and our reagent
calculator is that the the sprite
conditions are automatically updated for
the user there's modular processing of a
different protocol section as I
mentioned for the PCI free library
preparation portion or the PTR
enrichment and cleaner portions data
validation in our user interfaces ensure
that only proper drop-down selections
and inputs can be made so to see the
start button at the bottom if there's
any improper or entries such as sample
number greater than 96 then there will
be messages down with a start button is
indicating what needs to be corrected
before the user can execute the rung
there's all options for a minor offset
thermal cycling as well as the training
mode that reduces time to optimize and
test the method or train new users in
addition we also have flexible adaptive
lab where and transfer options we went
over in a little bit more detail on the
first webinar about a biomech method
launcher feature what essentially is is
a simplified user interface for
executing and launching a method swift
the swift method it was one of our early
methods that
with this new software capability and
some features that biomech method banya
provides our guided laboratory and
reagents setup which saves time and
reduces setup errors it steps the user
lab word by lab or through the next
setup and provides instructions for
reagents configuration in troughs or
region track specific to the options
selected in the user interface during
runtime the information tiles provide
real-time run updates and it also
doesn't the capability to be run
remotely or monitored from any
web-enabled device so this slide
compares manual and automated library
yields so you can see from the wide
range of inputs 100 nanograms on the
left down to 100 pv grams on the right
for e.coli genomic DNA input there's
consistency between the manual and
automated library yields this summarizes
our sequencing data of the genomic DNA
control as you can see we tested
variable fragment length there's 200 and
350 base pair inserts with a wide range
of sample inputs ranging from 150 grams
to 500 nanograms and you can see that
the percent alignment is extremely high
with very low PCR duplicates we also
tested ffpe material with various
fragment insert sizes again having
sufficient yield for nanomolar yield up
to 27 animal you'll depending on the
condition of the DSS de material and
resulting in high alignment and very low
PCR duplicates so the next example would
be related to targeted sequencing so
types of targeted sequencing our epic on
sequencing
using pcr-amplified specific target
regions or hydrogenation capture where
however you will hybridize target
specific probes followed by degrees
streptavidin be captured various
applications for targeted sequencing
would be cancer screen panels exome
sequencing or forensic str analysis
started sequencing challenge points for
various targeted sequencing applications
is a small number of samples which can
expand rapidly with multiple amplicon
reactions or restriction enzyme
digestion the automation method will
simplify the replication of sample
reactions set up and also manages and
tracks data associated with each well
reagent volume calculations can be
tedious and can fail have been properly
calculated and through the use of our
dynamic creating calculators those
calculations are performed automatically
based on the user selections made during
run options run option selection all of
them captured protocols there's
typically long overnight carbonization
reactions so that create a lot of
downtime on the instrumentation that you
don't want to be held up during those
long hybridization reactions so our
sequencing applications provide modular
workflows corresponding with the
manufacture of recommended stop points
we're long incubate incubations which
increase instrument productivity and
multi-application use so our systems can
be broken up in the module so that you
can perform other tasks on the
instrumentation while samples are being
incubated for long periods offset so our
application example for target capture
is the agilent technologies halen plex
protocol this is automated the
bottleneck 4000 and it was automated for
the Ion Torrent platform chemistry so
the agilent halo flex protocol is a
relatively simple protocol when you look
at these lies but actually it a little
bit more complex from
handling standpoint so essentially the
first step would be to digest into
nature your your sample DNA with a
series of restriction enzymes followed
by probe hybridization to the DNA
targets of interest excuse me followed
by purification and ligation of the
target regions and then a final
amplification enrichment by pcr so this
life kind of shows the complexity of the
restriction enzyme reaction setup so for
every sample there's eight restriction
enzymes that that has to be processed
you can imagine the amount of pipetting
that occurs for setting up multiple
reactions for each sample so the
automation alleviates this pipetting
intensive setup for river restriction
digestion and also removes the potential
for human error and they'll to provide
more consistent library preparation
again there's options for for you via
our user interface the modular protocol
provides more effective time management
and flexibility around overnight
incubation steps and it's an error there
it actually can process anywhere from
one to twelve samples with eight
restriction enzyme reactions for a total
of 96 reactions for played the automated
reagent calculator provides master mix
and reagent volumes based on a sample
number and other user options so this
slide demonstrates the consistency of
the biomech 4000 and manually generated
restriction fragments as you can see
with the two restriction digest there
that the thymic 4000 emanuel looked
consistent with effective restriction
digestion this slide shows consistency
of the biological sample prepared
manually and on the biomech 4000 and
you're generating the same
a bunch of Teresa's profile this is done
using the fragment analyzer from
advanced analytical okay comparison of
library science and yield are consistent
from the manual and automated problem
and sequencing results provide 800 ms
are 80 to 100 million reads with an
average read lengths of a hundred base
pair and a sequencing depth of greater
than 400 to 500 per samples with
approximately 100 1,000,000 reads we
have approximately eighty percent on
target reads and that's extremely
consistent between the manual and
automated prep so our uniformity in our
on target percentage between the manual
and biomed 4000 can be considered
comparable okay I want to summarize the
Agilent technology Taylor flex protocol
in the bottom at 4000 increases the
accuracy of library preps reduces human
error with samples for FEMA requires
viewer library failures and with manual
preps even with an experienced
technician the lower yield that we saw
with the manual or I'm sorry automated
press is not affect the sequencing
ability or results it was successful
with ffpe DNA provides cost-effective
time saving solution and increases
productivity and this development of the
Agilent protocol hello flex protocol was
done in partnership with Dartmouth
genomics and molecular biology course so
thank you to their team and I would like
to then and off the rest of the
presentation to my colleague Zack Smith
so we'll tell you about some RNA
sequencing application excellent time so
thank you very much Davis and thank you
all for hanging in here and so far with
us I just wanted to start by [ __ ] out
he discussed you know you know getting
on the genome
transcription so it's the last half this
talk is going to be about our own your
feedbacks applications that we've
automated the transcriptome is is an
interesting wild place RNA comes in a
variety of types with coding rnase your
traditional messenger RNA and then
you've got it seems like an
ever-expanding family of non-coding RNAs
including are divided similar neighs
transfer RNA is long non-coding RNAs
assistant Xavier and then a variety of
small non-coding RNAs including micro
RNAs PB interacting rnase and small
interfering RNAs just to name a few that
seems like this list keeps getting
longer the longer we the people we go
into the genome are in the transcriptome
excuse me so because you have all these
various species of RNA the tactics you
would use to get at them from a
sequencing standpoint can vary a little
bit on protocol and so what we're going
to go over today is specifically at em
RNA sequencing workflow total RNA
sequencing workflow at a small RNA
sequencing workflow I'm RNA sequencing
specifically targets mrna through the
use of a poly a recent technique using
all ago dt labeled beats basically what
you're doing or hybridizing you're all
the govt's to presently the beats to the
poly a tail and using those who fish out
the messenger RNA from your career total
RNA cool obviously you can use it with
prokaryotes as they don't have calling a
tail by march but in this work well for
mammalian species and works quite well
as a wide range of species so I just
wanted to direct your attention to I
guess would be my right this is the
enemy next altar of directional RNA
workflow for aluminum so as you can see
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to do our poly a capture are
using the all go dt beads then we will
fragment the resulting in messenger RNA
and prime it for reverse transcription
and then make our double stranded cdna
that following which protocol is very
similar to the DNA see workflow that
David described earlier we're going to
repair end we're going to do a failing
in the case of the ED chemistry we're
going to be doing a user excision
because they're adapters have an
interesting hairpin shape to them and
then we'll have apply the libraries and
that's pretty much the entirety of the
national am RNA sequencing workflow so
this is an example method we're going to
you know and so the challenge some of
the challenges that we would typically
see in mrna sequencing you know as
accommodation of RNA from variety of
sample types including provide examples
how are you going about dealing with
that ensuring good removal about
interesting / contaminating RNA species
such as ribosomal RNA which can
constitute the vast majority of any
total RNA sample and ensuring uniformity
in the sample processing so how we've
gone about doing that is we have a
method for the in them next RNA ultra
directional kit that allows me used by
the total RNA in combination with your
poly a enrichment or using a pre
purified RNA samples that you've used
some other kit off off deck views such
as regular Zurich it so that allows you
to get an RNA from your procare at
examples for removing uninteresting /
contaminating RNA species we're using a
combination of orbital shaking and tip
mixing for fishing mrna capture and
which results in good RNA removal using
probably capture and then we have the
ability of integrating an optional tier
about thermocycler as David mentioned
earlier on to our decks and that really
gives us the most uniform temperature
incubation temperatures across the plate
which results in more uniform libraries
it also gives you maximize walk away
that now to walk away time by allowing
the thermal cycling to occur bond that
so this is our this is the automation
solution we developed to the net next
RNA and ultra direction
from New England Biolabs this workflow
and user interface the data that I'm
about to present has been largely
developed on the FX although we do have
a customer site that's running this on a
be 4k so very pretty fluid is going to
go over touch on the user interface it's
very similar to the ones the data
presented it gives you a variety of
options including ability satisfy your
number of samples whether or not you've
been using on that thermocycler what
parts of the method you're going to
going to process that day and then a
variety of options around how you're
deploying your indices and what volumes
you want to elute the final Librarium
the method itself is broken up into
basically two large sub methods so over
here we'll have the method that runs
from total RNA it's all the way through
to double strand cdna cleanup and that
would include our mRNA purification and
fragmentation and priming second strand
first and second strand substances as
well to clean and then the second module
will include basically the library prep
part of the workflow so taking the
double strand cdna and subjecting it to
end repair a failing adapter ligation
cleanup and pcr enrichment so all told
this method can do it in 96 samples and
about nine and a half hours we have some
some manual data from any be that
suggests that trying to do that many
samples manually could take as long as
21 hours so if we've recognized
significant time savings on this method
using the FX obviously the the message
run time would be slightly longer on the
on the be 4k but if you're processing
you know fewer the 96 samples it should
be fairly comfortable I think ok so
let's dive into the data so for this
experiment we did a series of library
press using Angela University Minh
reference RNA able 25 milligram and
hundred nanogram inputs we had a series
of I believe three to four technical
replicates for each sample and I'm just
presenting some violent wiser traces of
the Finnish libraries here for both the
25 diagram replicate one and 100
repertoire and the compliment as you can
see we don't really have much in the way
that we don't actually have any adapter
drivers that we can visualize here and
then the yield look collective so all
six technical reference receive into a
single high seek run and the data was
analyzing doing a bio labs this graph
here is showing actually the technical
replicate reproducibility between our
are between our two input amounts so as
a graph on my left you'll see a
transcript expression correlation graph
the 25 anagram technical replicates
where we're looking at the fragments /
kilobase of X own per million read maps
the f km ratio and what we find here is
that when you're comparing those numbers
across the transcriptome we're seeing
very good reproducibility between our
two technical replicates for both the 25
nanogram input on the left and 400 an
agreement on the right we also the
violent competitions at NAB also did a
number of other analyses on the data so
we wanted one things we would like to
know is you know we're on the tram you
know we're in the genome of the reason
mapping to and as you can see here on
the Left we've got the 25 nanogram reads
are you know the module with vast
majority of our having to coding regions
which means we are doing an efficient
messenger RNA pool and if you look at
the graph on the you know obviously we
do have some small amount of ribosomal
sequence left but it's you know less
than five percent and we do have a small
amount of intronic regions means we're
also capturing non non mature messenger
RNAs as well the ground is pretty much
put you know replicated with 100 a gram
and put on your right as well on the
bottom of this line we're looking at
transcriptome coverage so this is a
termination of where the reads are
mapping along Japan along with
transcription of five prime to three
prime end I newly what you'd like to see
is a uniform distribution of reads which
would indicate that our reverse
transcription and not biasing the sample
one way or another and then the sample
itself is a good quality will
talk some more about that in the next
example method because I have some data
from that that would be interesting and
the other thing we wanted to know is the
vo for library complexity how many pcr
duplicates are we seeing in these
libraries and terribly not surprising
that 800 nanogram inputs which are the
green bars on this chart has
significantly fewer events of PCR
duplication than the 25 milligram inputs
generally with any NGS kids that you're
working with the more sample input you
have the library print editor library
will beef I realize that some people are
limited on just the type of sample of
what they're able to get but more info
collge it will get you a better library
typically the other thing we wanted to
look at what the into the correlation
between and be 2500 nanogram input so
this is a get another MP km ratio charge
and we see very good correlation between
the 25 degree of inputs which means that
our intimate material is not biasing the
results that we're getting these as far
as this metric is concerned okay so we
talked a little bit about messenger RNA
sequencing the next thing I touching is
what's referred to as total RNA
sequencing so the idea here is that
we're interested in many different
species as we can capture so this will
be our messenger RNA and this would be
you know our long non-coding RNAs but
the problem with is that you've still
got our red zone RNA and and in some
particular sample types you've also got
other high abundance transcripts I
hemoglobin that you would read that you
would be wasting your time sequencing
and then you need to get rid of them
somehow so the idea behind this this
particular workflow is instead of using
the volume of etps to fish the messenger
RNA out of the sample what we're doing
is we're using some sort of beat capture
or some sort of hybridization events to
hybridize the high abundance transcripts
and remove them from the pool and then
sequence everything else so the case of
alumina sequencing technologies is in
the right of 0 kit there's actually a
bead based in Hampshire New England
Biolabs uses a
just proves that then bind to the to the
high london's transcripts of them those
are digested away to the two very good
ways of getting rid of those high
abundance transcripts that would reduce
the effectiveness of your sequencing
experiment the other thing that's great
about this particular way of doing
things is that it works well with our
apts from RNA from prokaryotes because
you're not relying on the poly a tail
but one thing to design with these sorts
of Hatcher experiments is that depending
on I mean the capture probes are
designed against a certain collection of
model organisms and a good working with
a model organism that is not one of the
canonical 13 from the NIH that you're
not working with humans mice a rat or
rabbit haces for example you might see
you reduced efficiency in the rrna or
the high abundance transcript knocked
down based on the fact that we're
working on sequence similarity to do
these hybrids ation events so just
something to keep in mind as you go
about doing these sorts of experiments
so challenge points for this would be
accommodating RNA again accommodating
RNA provide bright sample types
including on model organisms and
ensuring a good removal your ribosomal
you know rii ribosome we're on your high
abundance transcripts so again for for
this particular solution our method
design allows for the use of any of the
four limited run 20 depletion ships that
are currently available and for the
orbital shavings so for the high limits
transcript removal we rely on a
combination war little shading is it
mixing to make sure we get good bead
mixing and resuspension for good rrna
removal so um so this is the example
whether we're use for this so this is
the alumina tristique stranded total RNA
and we've developed this one we get on
the FX but we do have customers that are
using this on the smaller platforms
again the workflow is very similar to
the messenger RNA they have RNA
sequencing example for the luminous and
an index stranded alter any be next holy
directional kit but major difference is
the ribosomal beaver
rather than the college capture so we
conducted two seed sets of sequencing
experiments with this when
collaborations with Dana Farber so they
were looking at basically we had to two
experiments one of the four samples
using FF for fresh frozen material and
one of the FFPE and those were only four
samples but they were seedless to a
depth of 150 million reads approximately
free sample and then we have a smaller
experiment with 20 universal human
reference RNA samples that were
sequenced to a depth of approximately 10
to 25 million reads and then this is a
graph showing the alignment that you're
that you're seeing here for the reeds
after they were sequence and Matt back
the universe at the human reference
genome as you can see in both cases we
had our in the fresh frozen versus the
FFP we had slightly higher rates of on
the line reads for the for the FFPE
samples but not to battle imbalance in
this slide we are showing the abundant
breathe so we're looking for contaminant
in this particular slide here so as you
can see on the graph on the left when
we're looking at percent adapters and
we're looking at reeds that are mapping
back to mitochondria or 5s ribosomal
human DNA or repeal human ribosomal RNA
are probably we are seeing extremely low
rates of math activities and avid reads
in the fresh frozen or in the big into
fresh frozen samples we are seeing
slightly higher family reads back to the
these penetrates back in the FFPE
samples but if you know the ground on
the axis on the y-axis is grass none of
these readings get above four and a half
percent so they're leads the vast
majority of reeds are actually mapping
to the targets that were that were
interested in getting at and the same
was true with the universal human
reference samples and actually the data
was somewhat better than that we're
having to less than two percent
contaminants this chart is kind of busy
but I'm going to summarize it by saying
that we have fairly media fairly uniform
medium in sir sizes for the universal
human reference as you see on the the 20
or so you HR samples and for the FP and
press version as well we do see higher
rates of duplication if no fresh fresh
frozen samples as opposed to the FFPE
samples and then the third column is are
stranded so this kid implies as well as
the next kid does it as well in fluid
EGP strategy for marking the Strand
that's complementary to the RNA molecule
into the RNA molecule which means we're
maintaining the Strand information of
where those beads which strand of the
DNA of those raids with transcribed from
and so in this case we had over ninety
seven percent of our raids were mapping
to the correct strand which was really
really quite good and we did a little
differential expression analysis on the
FFPE versus the fresh frozen we were
seeing a slight amount of differential
expression in between fifty and you know
once than 100 genes though became the
fresh frozen versus the FFPE samples one
of the other things we want to really
interested in knowing is how he as far
as alignment and coverage how would
those reads comparing versus the for the
fresh frozen versus the FFP material so
again we're going to look at a
transcript coverage graph from the on
the left side of the screen so the blue
arrow that you can see there is pointing
to the FFPE samples as you can see
they're slightly shifted towards the
three prime end of the transcript has a
3 prime end of the ideal transcripts and
we're seeing slightly higher receivable
you know quite a bit higher than tronic
reads in the FFPE samples so this is
underscores the fact that certain types
of rnase don't work well with certain
kids so the strain of total kids has
worked fairly well for fresh frozen and
works well for fresh RNA but it could be
better for FFP
describe samples and this is part of the
reason why I'm going to develop the RNA
access kit was helped get around some of
the problem some of the challenges with
working with FFP drive samples when
we're looking at our universal human
reference again when we're looking at
the transcripts I went into the to the
ideal transcripts and we're looking at
coverage controls we're not seeing
really any difference based on the
number of inputs so the grass going for
the left to right are from 50 100 200
and 500 datagrams of input material and
we're seeing very consistent data
between between those various input
types are input amounts ok so we've
talked about mrt sequencing and we
talked about total RNA sequencing the
next thing I wanted to discuss briefly
what a small RNA sequencing so smaller
nays are very tricky to get at the kids
that are developed around them and set
up you know doing some sort of pre
purification and then fragmenting the
samples and priming them they actually
instead use a direct ligation strategy
where we are locating adapters directed
to the small RNA molecules and in part
this is to make them large enough that
we can manipulate them with what I would
prefer standard NGS techniques with like
these like sprite captures and whatnot
so this is the nav next small learning
workflow and what we're doing is we're
simply ligating on an adapter to the 2
the 3 prime end of a small learning and
on the 5 prime end and then we're going
to land our reverse transfer primer for
reverse transcription and then we are
going to go ahead and do our first
strand synthesis and then do PCR to
finish filling the library this is
extremely technical of most smaller
network flows so because we're doing
direct ligation to RNA molecules that
that is a challenge for even someone
doing it manually the reason why is that
the RNA like aids that are being used
are the efficient
see if you like Asian reaction drops
dramatically if you if you managed to
regain secondary structure in either
you're after or you're the target you're
trying to like 82 so you do you heat the
nature the samples to make them linear
and then you need to keep them cold
while you're working on them to make
sure that you reduce the amount of
secondary structure formation so for our
patient solution we utilize on deck
cooling out some land and lab where that
basically cool blocks to reduce the
incidence of that secondary structure
deformation which ensures high rotation
efficiency one of the things that
particular tis an atv next smaller naked
is that they have developed a protocol
for using our debased spy technology for
doing this I selection on the final
library however they also recognize that
you might want to use a gel cut or
pippin prep to do that final size
selection so we in the automation
solution we've developed a method to
where it does any one of those options
so this is this is our example methods
of this net bag small RNA my career prep
kit for Illumina the workflow has been
developed is it has been broken up into
three major modules of blue red and
green so we're doing our three prime and
after ligation rrt hybridization and
five prime and then we'll do our pcr
amplification and then our post pcr
purification and science elections this
maintains all the the kids stopping
points this to this solution was
developed for the p4k and for the
biomech FX and we have the data I'm
going to be presenting today it's from
the bottom at 4000 so if you process
it's 24 samples and we give you a
variety of options including you know
specify how you know how much you want
to dilute the adapters primers already
so if you're working with a sufficiently
large amount of material you might not
want to do that or if you're dealing
with a RNA example those derived from a
micro
RNA in rich environment such as brain
tissue then you might not want to delete
your adapters and primers but if you're
dealing with you know very dilute on a
sample or you're dealing with sandal it
comes from a tissue that's not known for
enriching smaller ice that you might
want to lose your adapters and primers
to reduce the incidence of after diaper
formation and so we give you that option
right of the method and then we can also
meet the option of whether or not you
want the instrument to deploy the the
index of barcodes automatically or if
you want to specify files do that
yourself and what kind of post piece
your size selection option you want to
perform either enter XP based or pippin
prep or some sort of off deck gel cut so
this is a Bible under trees over length
of a small RNA library before in after
the beef a 5 selection that available
with kit as you can see the blue line
here this is a generate from Agilent
micro RNA control Arnie so the blue
lines blue trace is here are the
background the ones of the Fulton a
stripper for size selection and then
after size selection is the red trace
here which has our approximately 100 and
you know 20 or so paid 140 based care
products that were interested in
sequencing so after adapter trip so we
sequence the samples were sent to a TV
for sequencing and analysis after we did
you know why she'd run we need to trim
the rees back my grenades tend to range
anywhere from 18 to 32 nucleotides and
so we're getting our small RNA is
approximately 22 which is right where we
were hoping Stephen or RNA from Colin's
brain and the agilent micro RNA control
and we did this at two NP 2 500
datagrams or 100 grams so when we lose
base base to do the sequencing analysis
here and as you can see we did we map
the reeds back to the river to the
reference genome in this case
twenty to thirty percent of it was
mapping back to various micrornas we did
the abundant read and given ribosomal
primarily but we did see a variety of
you know somewhere between twenty
percent approximate there were others
including pee-wee's and Langston the
other small RNA species that you would
expect to find and this is a
differential expression heat map based
on the MIR na and I severe expression
from the NEP next call RNA libraries so
this this particular heat map reading
indicates a high-level expression right
indicate low levels of expression used
ec2 to perform the differential
expression analysis and completely
unsurprisingly we found that micro RNA
that was typically upregulated in brain
tissue was upregulated versus the
agilent control and likewise with the
colon but it was nice to see that we you
know results that we should have been
getting when we were doing these
comparisons we were getting so with that
I just wanted to add a brief plug for
our NGS flash page so business info
Beckman com ing s for more information
for our automated solutions and thank
you for your time we have to take any
questions now thank you David and Zach
your presentations quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box sound
like clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window David and Zach will answer as
many questions as time permits and the
first question is any automation for Ion
Torrent RNA seek library prep work flows
yet whole transcriptome small RNAs
cumpla seek
you may be the question yes of course
any automation for ion torrent aren't na
seek laboratory prep work flows yet
whole transcriptome small RNAs ampliphi
recurrently the process is developing an
amplitude solution for the X the ion we
didna did show some ion torrent data in
this presentation for halo plex but
other than that no we have ample t has
been the one we primarily have been
working on lately the higher end w peaks
in the small RNA seek that are purified
away are those due to Colin kamut
reserved small RNAs or doctors alright
Clennam sure none of the in the smaller
any data you're referring to the overlay
graph the ones that are purified away
our larger RNA fragments in the control
arm and the control RNA Agilent that
were ligated successfully so the you
know for the army ligation basically you
need 85 prime hydroxyl on a 3 prime
phosphate on the RNA molecule that
you're ligating to and you will see that
sort of in combination is happening
occasionally so those will get amplified
it because they have been converted in
the library successfully so that's part
of the reason why we're doing this I
selection is 20 and specifically on the
size fragments ranging from 130 to 140
basis in length applications you
currently have four biomat 4000 so for
the violent 4000 we have obviously we
showed the true see Hanno's / pcr free
method for the violent 4000 that next
small RNA from a new england biolabs
we've got a variety of pcr set up an
extraction
industries as well on the violent 4000
and we're in the process of expanding
that portfolio we do have a number of
customer developed or customer or
Engleman and methods on the biomech 4000
I don't have the list in front of the
era of the moment oh okay now we're just
kind of pause for a moment I policy have
more questions for coming in and while
we're waiting um i would like to once
again thank David Horvath and Zach Smith
for their presentations do you have any
any final comments this point of it
thank you for attending you know thank
you again for everyone for showing up
everybody it's good that you were able
to take the time out of your day to
listen to our hi do you have another
pull-up and so on while people are
answering the poll I would just like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
would also like to thank our sponsor
beckman coulter life sciences for
underwriting today's educational web
cast as a reminder this webinar is the
second in a three-part series please
save the date for the final upcoming
presentation part 3 mission possible
automating NGS sample prep for
challenging samples and niche
applications would be presented on july
twenty registration is now open for part
three so feel free to visit the lab
groups website confirm your attendance
today this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credit please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credit this webcast can be
viewed on demand through December 23rd
2016 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time bye